I was planning on sending it in a cheek swab today Monday, but Saturday was and Ivy was,
Ivy started coming out and instead today I'm at Medstat getting a steroid shot and a prescription
for more. It's person talking about poison ivy. I have it really bad. I assume I should wait to
send a cheek swab in. How long? So given the rest of this question, this person is talking about
poison ivy. Poison ivy started coming out, meaning maybe a rash from poison ivy started
coming out of the skin. So how long should I wait before I do a cheek swab? Well, the poison ivy
rashes and get effects of cheek swab for your cancer, so you could still do the send a cheek swab
for the cancer. Also, once you're recommended, recommendation for treating poison ivy
OTC over the color. I really want to avoid the shot, but the poison ivy is too bad this time.
PSA don't pet strange dogs, so you don't know what they've been doing.
So there's a lot of treatment things for poison ivy that you could search on the internet.
I remember when we lived in the woods, we had lots of poison ivy and I got to the point where I was
basically just immune to it. I could literally pick it out of my garden and I didn't even break out,
so we just got to that point. We have poison ivy where our office is now because our office
is a whole cell of 12 acres. And I get exposed to poison ivy every year, get a little bit of a rash
as long as I try not to itch it. I don't get it too bad of an issue, but there are some people that
end up developing at IGG. We end the bodies to poison ivy and then they break out really bad and
they get really blistered in such. But it is the, I think it's both your cereal acid oil that is
really the contaminated to poison ivy. So the, you have to get the oil off your vine. So using
you can't just wash the skin with water when you're exposed to poison ivy because it won't,
because oil repels water so you have to use some sort of oil, a cleaner to get it off your body.
So many people recommend some of the cleaners that would be used, some of the solvents that would be
used as hand cleaners for like mechanics. I can't remember the name of them right now, but I used to
have a, I think it was a group or something like that that was in a jar. I had in my garage in my
work bench so that when I got really oily skin from working with my chainsaw or something,
I would grab some of that and clean off my hands. Using something like that that's oil
soluble that will help pull that out off the skin is the best thing. Once you already get the
reaction of poison ivy, there are anti-inflammatory things you could do from the nutritional standpoint,
but still it's hard to get to the skin. Obviously most people are using the steroid creams and stuff
for poison ivy and that gets to be difficult. I had a patient years ago that had a company that
sold poison ivy treatment stuff, but I can't remember the name of that company. I actually gave
me some of the product to try. I believe I still haven't somewhere. I've never had to use it. My
kids have never had to use it. We don't have poison ivy in our house. We only have 20 acres
at our house. We just don't have poison ivy there. So we haven't had to use it. So
I think they probably sell their stuff on Amazon. I would look on Amazon for a poison ivy treatment
and there's probably some good products out there. This guy used to score that they started their
company because them or one of their kids or something had a form of a horrible reaction. So they
did the research and put the products together. I would try something.